you're a stray man you can do anything
you want this beer doesn't taste good
but I like how it's making me feel why
are you clutching that large feral hog
like it's a child that's not a feral hog
it's punchy I definitely think Monty
fits in munchie is lovable uh to
everyone
um but he's a bit uh wall-eyed yeah I
I'm not sure about Monty's intelligence
level uh if Machi had a human voice uh
I'm curious who would play who would
play them I don't know but if you need
someone who was very very lovable and
very unpredictable that's right but I
think that Manchester surprise
might have slowed down the journey a bit
uh not the fastest uh not the fastest of
dogs
[Music]
let's see what kind of effect that has
on it I feel like I don't know if she
would fit in great because she might uh
eat the dogs she would certainly bring
some energy to the to the proceedings
I think that the maternal Instinct might
kick in and she might be very protective
of those Cubs
and I sure don't want to be a Will Forte
[Laughter]
if she makes it back to the house
with the uh with the intention of
Revenge I think that that I think it
would have been a a slightly different
ending I also think um mushroom bear
would be a very different film
of cocaine bear also had mushrooms oh
maybe both yeah that's a good idea
interesting
[Music]
welcome you all to Cloud Cuckoo Land
Unikitty uh would uh make make this a
lot a lot of fun I think it was really
an oversight not including Unikitty in
in the movie
show up in the in the mushroom sequences
is beyond me yeah
I mean I mean I guess there's dogs and
cats you know you know so they might not
be as welcoming to her but I think you
can't help but be one over by her
positivity and charms I think she would
go well if if the dogs could get over it
also she's made of plastic so you know
they might you know try and if they try
to sniff her butt I don't know that they
would smell anything they might not
trust that
it's hard to see where say where it
would go but it could go one of one of
three ways she had a a an animated
series where puppycorn was her friend
who was a dog unicorn so I think she has
a lot of experience working with dogs so
I think she would be all right
[Music]
but we really have worked with a lot of
animals it turns out Steve we do hear
his voice uh of Neil Patrick Harris but
he is
not doesn't have a lot interesting to
say I feel like the dogs might
reject him the way they rejected the
Josh Gad narrator dog but I don't know
maybe Steve might still come along
Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs does a
poor job of representing Steve's
internality
um and hopefully we hope to make up for
him
with them
he's taking any damn winner I think
spider cat has the powers uh that would
be helpful for them on their mission so
if spider cat was down to join I think
the dogs would be lucky a cat with the
power of a spider who can cough up a
hairball web yeah would they be able to
put their differences aside
we have a common goal it is true that
with
Cat power comes great responsibility
that's what I suppose that they would
she would figure it out I kind of feel
like the Jamie Foxx uh bug character
would be skeptical of of spider cat and
uh
needs some maybe although one thing he's
not skeptical about is inter species
romance but I mean is a couch really a
species
depends how you look at it